welcome back the collaboration Center
foundation's night I'm Blanc Gala is
Wednesday and you still have time to get
involved here to tell us more about the
gala and the organization is Linda
tachet the CEO of collaboration Center
Foundation welcome and we've got John
Simmons from Firefly who's part of the
galley who's brought some food we'll get
to that in a second let's let's start
Linda first with the organization tell
us more about what you guys do
absolutely so I'm a parent of a young
adult with autism and he has some other
disabilities happening so in 2019 we
came up with this concept to create a
campus that invites all disabilities
intellectual Developmental and physical
to the property to just have this
wonderful experience with a lifespan of
services and treating the family
grandparents and caregivers as well you
guys are doing amazing things thank you
this is the big Galley you had more last
year's the second annual so tell us more
about the Gallow in one second yeah so
the gala is at our Ranch so we have a
five acre ranch campus go on okay and
it's a beautiful fun food fair open bars
we have some circax happening that is
it's white Ranch gland and it's outside
under thousands of lights and we just
are here to raise awareness and funding
to build out our campus I love the
attire white Ranch Glam yeah and you do
have you do have a silent auction taking
place as well what are some of the items
some of the items so we have one right
here so we have the three day three
night stay at Gig Harbor Washington and
it's a free flight and then we also for
our live auction one of our packages is
a private VIP NASCAR Experience that is
not available to the public I've done
the public NASCAR experiences those are
incredible you've got a private one this
is fantastic and you've got when it
comes to the food the best of the best
yes John first off why did you decide to
get involved with the organization
Well we'd like to do anything and you
know to help the community and
everything but last year we actually
bought a table and we had this great
food I'm like how come we're not
involved right right so we were like hey
can we serve some food this year and
they said okay so here we are yes and
did you have your white lamb outfit
ready to go yeah same one I wore last
year perfect yeah what do you have what
are some of the food items we'd expect
on Wednesday this is what we're serving
I have a steak and mushroom skewer with
the paquillo puree a little bit of pesto
some uh garlic cream sauce and our
famous bacon wrapped taste red wine
reduction blue cheese chili oil it has
like a ranch feel to it that's right
there's a little meaties yeah yeah we
had the guys from Yellowstone on the
show earlier now we're talking to you
Linda where does the money raise where
does that go the money you guys are
gonna raise on Wednesday so first of all
it stays in our community which is
wonderful it's going to help build out
the rest of the campus for the
recreation center and the other thing
it's going to grow our Pathways program
so that when families need to know where
resources are they can call us for free
and we will guide them through anything
they need yeah zona's watching and they
want to get involved maybe they can't
maybe they can't bid on something maybe
they can't make it down there on
Wednesday but they want to volunteer
their time you're looking for volunteers
yeah absolutely we're looking for
volunteers and just so you know people
can vid if they're not going to show
yeah jump online and do it absolutely
fine but we need volunteers and then
most importantly if there's families out
there that need a diagnosis or treatment
or health health services please contact
us and we will guide you to someone that
can help you I love it thank you so much
for joining us John thank you and thank
you for bringing the food to the event
on Wednesday night and Blanc it's
Wednesday this this Wednesday at six
o'clock it's located at the Magnificent
magnificent Las Vegas Ranch uh
collablv.org for information in Las
Vegas now we'll be right back